um
good afternoon on the eve
of the 57th march on washington i will
speak about
the recent events in kenosha wisconsin
the wildfires raging across the
california coast
to the rocky mountains the storm
which is working its way through texas
louisiana and the gulf coast
and most of all about who we are as a
country
we are a nation that at its best
loves protects and helps our fellow
americans
today we see pain hurt
and destruction in the ashes of
wildfires and the damage of hurricane
laura we encourage everyone to continue
following guidance from your local
authorities to stay
safe and joe and i pledge to be
there for those whose lives have been
turned upside down
those who will need help from neighbors
strangers
and our government to make it through to
build back
to restore your lives and your
communities
we also see pain hurt and destruction
in the aftermath of yet another black
man
shot by police jacob blake shot seven
times
in the back in broad daylight
in front of his three young sons
seven times in the back
in broad daylight in front of his three
young sons
as vice president biden put it the shots
fired
at mr blake pierced the soul
of our nation it's sickening to watch
it's all too familiar and it
must end thankfully he is alive today
but he is fighting for his life and he
shouldn't have to be
my heart goes out to the blake family as
they endure
an ordeal that is tragically common
in our country joe and i spoke with them
yesterday
they are an amazing group of people with
extraordinary courage
even in their pain and their grief
even as they seek justice for their son
they spoke about the need to end the
violence
and heal our nation
i've had conversations like this with
far too many mothers and fathers
but you will see and hear no one with
more courage
more character and more moral clarity
people are rightfully angry and
exhausted
and after the murders of brianna
and george and ahmad and so many others
it's no wonder people are taken to the
streets
and i support them we must always defend
peaceful protest and peaceful protesters
we should not confuse them with those
looting and committing acts of violence
including the shooter who was arrested
for murder
and make no mistake we will not let
these vigilantes and extremists
derail the path to justice
here is my promise to those mothers and
fathers and all who stand
with them in a biden harris
administration
you will have a seat at the table
in the halls of congress and in the
white house
we all grew up reciting the pledge of
allegiance
but now we must give real meaning
to its words one nation
under god indivisible
with liberty and justice for
all justice
let's talk about that because the
reality
is that the life of a black person in
america has never been treated as fully
human
and we have yet to fulfill that promise
of equal justice under law
we will only achieve that when we
finally come together
to pass meaningful police reform and
broader
criminal justice reform and acknowledge
yes acknowledge and address
systemic racism we will only come closer
to achieving that when we finally come
together
we have come a long way in our country
toward building a more perfect union
and the time is now right now to take
the next step forward
and even as we experience this reckoning
with racial injustice
we must also confront another crisis
the pandemic that has torn apart
so many lives the numbers that define
this crisis are staggering
we cannot look the other way or allow
ourselves to become
numb to them nearly 6 million
confirmed cases of the coronavirus
180 000 lives lost
more than 50 million claims for
unemployment
this year alone we need to see
and we need to hear what is happening in
our country
the quiet desperation that has taken
over
so many lives in america the family
packing into their car at five o'clock
in the morning
hoping the local food bank still has
something left
when they get to the front of the line
the 50 year old store manager
who's been laid off and knows he can't
pay the rent on the first of the month
the mothers and fathers stretched to the
breaking point
working from home while helping their
kids with their online classes
just trying to hold it all together the
small business owners
economic engines of our communities who
are shutting their doors
every day the nurse
getting ready for her afternoon shift
who has seen
so much suffering and death in recent
months
and wonders how much more can she
bear to witness the family
grieving the loss of their grandmother
who's been in a nursing home
and who they couldn't even visit over
the last three months
of her life the alarming and
disproportionate rate at which black
latino and indigenous families are
contracting and
dying of covet 19.
that is the reality of america right now
a reality completely absent
from this week's republican national
convention
because unlike the democratic convention
which was very clear-eyed
about the challenges we are facing and
how we will tackle them
the republican convention is designed
for one purpose to soothe
donald trump's ego to make him feel good
but here's the thing he's the president
of the united states and it's not
supposed to be
about him it's supposed to be
about the health and the safety and the
well-being of the american people
and on that measure donald trump has
failed
you see at its most basic level
donald trump doesn't understand the
presidency
he thinks it's all about him well it's
not
it's about you it's about all of us
the people
as a lawyer and advocate when i would
rise to speak in a courtroom
i'd say the following words kamala
harris
for the people and that is why i stand
today
to speak for the people
because we know the truth donald trump
has failed at the most basic
and important job of a president
of the united states he failed
to protect the american people
plain and simple trump showed
that we in the legal profession would
call a reckless
disregard for the well-being of the
american people
a reckless disregard for the danger
a pandemic would pose to american lives
for the devastation it would do to our
economy
for the damage it would do to
communities of color who have been
subjected
to structural racism for generations
for the chaos that would upend our daily
lives
make it impossible for many of our
children to go to school
make it impossible to live normally
and with the sense of certainty
he never appreciated that a president
swears an oath before god
and country to protect america
against threats seen and unseen
it's his duty it's his obligation
to protect us and yet
he has failed miserably
here's the thing donald trump's
incompetence is nothing new
that has always been on full display
but in january of this year it became
deadly
that's when the threat of a virus that
it would endanger the world
first emerged trump dismissed the threat
but joe biden sound the alarm
it would be the beginning of a pattern
that persists
to this day trump telling us not to
worry
that the virus will quote disappear that
a quote
miracle is coming joe biden
saying we need a plan a national
strategy
a president who is willing to lead
willing to be a role model for our
nation
for our children
trump still doesn't have a plan he still
doesn't have
a plan joe biden released his first plan
in march
and here's what you have to understand
about the nature of a pandemic
it's relentless you can't stop it with a
tweet
you can't create a distraction and hope
it'll go away
it doesn't go away by its nature
a pandemic is unforgiving
if you get it wrong at the beginning the
consequences are catastrophic
and it's very hard to catch up you don't
get a second chance
at getting it right well
president trump he got it wrong from the
beginning
and then he got it wrong again
and again and the consequences
have been catastrophic and
here's why trump has been so unwilling
and unable to deal with this crisis
first he was fixated on the stock market
over fixing the problem he tweeted about
it
consistently during this period he was
convinced
that is if his administration focused on
this virus
it would hurt the market and hurt his
chances of being reelected
that mattered to him more than saving
american lives
second right at the moment that we
needed donald trump to be tough on the
chinese government
he caved on january 24th
he praised the transparency of the
chinese government he said quote
china has been working hard to contain
the coronavirus
the united states greatly appreciates
their efforts
and transparency it will all work out
well
but they weren't being transparent they
blocked
public health inspectors from our cdc
from getting access and information that
they needed
to protect american lives
donald trump stood idly by
and folks it was a deadly decision
instead of rising to meet the most
difficult moment
of his presidency donald trump
froze he was scared
and he was petty and vindictive
on a call with governors across the
country on march 16th
he told them it wasn't his job to get
personal protective equipment
to front line workers he said quote
respirators ventilators all of the
equipment
try getting it yourselves unquote
on that day we had about five thousand
cases
as a nation today we have nearly six
million
even now some eight months into this
crisis
donald trump still won't take
responsibility
he still won't act and the tragedy
in all of this is it didn't have to be
this bad just look around
it's not like this in the rest of the
world
all we needed guys
all we needed was a competent president
one who was willing to listen
willing to lead take responsibility
have a plan do their job
well joe biden will be that president
he's got a national strategy he's more
than ready to lead
every month since march as this pandemic
has unfolded
joe biden has updated the steps he would
take
to save american lives and he's done it
based on what
every scientist every expert every
economist
said we should be doing as president
joe biden will put a plan into effect on
day one
develop and deploy rapid tests with
immediate results
make sure testing treatments and
ultimately a vaccine
reach all americans including
communities of color who have
historically been left behind
manufacture the medical supplies and
protective equipment we need
and make them right here in america
so we're never again at the mercy of
china and other foreign countries
to protect our own people
joe and i will make sure our schools
have all the resources they need
to be open and safe and effective
put politics aside and not silence the
experts
so the public gets the information they
need
and deserve and put in place
a nationwide mask mandate
because in joe's words it's not a burden
to protect each other
and he says that because the thing about
joe is he knows
we're all in this together donald trump
says there's nothing he could have done
to prevent all this death here's the
truth
barack obama and joe biden had a program
called predict that tracked emerging
diseases in places like
china i'm going to repeat that
the program tracked emerging
diseases in places like china
trump cut it they
detected a team and and
and created that team in the national
security council
to global health and security dedicating
them
to the work of global health and
security and biodefense
donald trump eliminated it
they implemented standards for nursing
homes
to improve infection control
donald trump is erasing them
before the virus hit trump made our
country vulnerable
after it was struck he failed
to do what was necessary
as it continues he's making it worse
every day
just this week just this week
the social security administration said
a cut to social security
like the one trump is proposing would
end
disability benefits within one year
and end all benefits within three years
so let me be as clear as possible
if donald trump's extreme proposal
goes into effect the checks that
american seniors are relying on
that you rely on to pay your bills
to buy your medicine to live
will stop coming the very people
who have suffered so greatly in this
crisis
it's unthinkable and in the middle of a
health crisis made
worse by his own actions donald trump is
in court right now
trying to throw out the entire
affordable care act
including the protections it provides
for people with pre-existing conditions
so that means if you are fortunate
enough to survive covid19
insurers could deny you coverage for
treating
any long-term effects now
president trump won't tell you any of
this
at the republican convention tonight
and we all know he's not changing
the president he has been is the
president he will be
but we have a chance to right
these wrongs and put america on a
better path forward
one where the leaders we elect
listen to the experts and
follow the best medical guidance to keep
us
and our families healthy and safe
one where we take meaningful action
against systems and traditions of
oppression
one where we stop fanning the flames of
hate and division and treat
one another with the respect and the
dignity that each one of us deserves
as joe biden said in his acceptance
speech
we have a choice between the light
and the dark
i believe america will choose
the light thank you
you